let me share my business model with you
my formula with you the very same
formula that I teach all my students
across the world learn to be someone who
has done
what's that believed Nations Evan I
believe in you and this channel is
designed to be part of your daily
success routine so today let's learn how
to make $100 a day with Dan lock also if
you want to know Dan and other
successful entrepreneurs have to say
about building unstoppable confidence
check out my 250 for confidence series
where every day for the next 254 days I
will send you a morning video for free
to help you build your confidence the
link to join is in the description below
after you practice Marshall you develop
this natural self confidence not
cockiness but you develop this natural
self confidence so everybody is chasing
the next thing the next big thing the
next shiny object when what ideal what
my students do is we are using the
oldest ways to make money see most
people they are looking at it yet they
are stepping over dollars to pick up
times what I'm talking about I'm talking
about the good old telephone that's
right
the good old phone simple simple tool to
make hundred dollars a day let me share
my business model with you my formula
with you the very same formula that I
teach all my students across the world
the high ticket closing methodology
here's how it's gonna work imagine this
there are companies out there nowadays
it costs more than ever to acquire
customers so most companies you notice
this advertising is costing more money
than ever because it's more competitive
than ever in the marketplace so a lot of
companies when they are selling any kind
of product most product under $200 most
of time those I want to call the initial
product that they are using those
products in the marketplace companies
entrepreneurs they're selling these
products hopefully to devotion ship with
a
is to to break the wallet and just start
the relationship start the conversation
all the money is made after that $200 is
spent when they realize hey you know
what once my customer trusts our brand
trust our company now we can follow up
with them and offer them our the
products and services that are at the
2,000 3,000 5,000 10,000 20,000 25,000
or more that's where the money it's made
here's the problem those offers I refer
them as high ticket offers 5,000 10,000
25,000 50,000 dollars those cells they
need to be close on their phone very
rarely people buy something at that kind
of price point looking at a video or
just looking at a website they need to
have that one-on-one conversation so
what does that have to do with you
that's where you come in imagine this
let's say you are closing for a company
or you're closing for an entrepreneur
let's say their offer is $1,000 and if
you're good closer you have good closing
skill they are willing to pay you $100
which is 10% of the sell 10% commission
that's $100 so I want you to think about
it if you're closing some of these
packages some of these products and
services 1000 bucks
you make $100 and sale that's $100 a day
all you need to do is what to make one
thing go sell a day that's it one single
sale a day you get your 100 bucks what
is your cost zero how many websites you
have to build
zero how many products you to buy 0 why
because you're not selling your own
products you're not starting your own
offers you're selling other people's
offers the company the influencer the
entrepreneur they are doing all the
marketing they do you want to lead
generation they're driving all the
traffic they are building a funnel
they're creating content they're writing
a blog they're creating videos they're
doing a press release they're doing 90%
of the work but yet they don't make the
money until someone like you and me get
on the phone and close those high ticket
sales this is one of those very rare
skills that you can make your hundred
dollars a day
with no expense and no overhead now you
may be thinking well then are you
talking about being like a annoying
telemarketer you doesn't mean after cold
call people there's nothing I have to do
a lot of prospecting oh my god like I
can't do that I'm a shy person I'm not
very talkative it's not about none of
that I am talking about talking to
people who have put up their hand I'm
talking about talking the prospects we
have gone through a series of steps who
have fill in the application form and
then book a time to speak with you as a
high-ticket closer and then you close
those sales that's what I teach zero
cold calling has nothing to do with
building a website you don't have to do
anything online and you don't have a
Coke or a single person that's the power
of high ticket closing thank you guys
for watching I hope you enjoyed this is
still a new series that I'm testing out
so I'd love to get your feedback do you
like it you want me to continue jumping
to find more this making money
opportunities join me to find more of
these videos with people teaching you
how to make more money let me know in
the comments below
hi this is Dan Locke if you're a fan of
Evans work if you want to know exactly
how the model my success I want to
invite you to join me for a special
online training all you have to do is
click on a link below you can join me
for absolutely no charge so click a link
below and I will see you in class
and if you want more jane Locke check
the top 50 rules video I made on if the
link is right there next to me I think
you'll enjoy it continue to believe and
I'll see you there if your life stinks
is your fault we take responsibility for
all action our money is not the
important money doesn't buy happiness